I
okay good morning everyone today we have
Mario McHale Krell as our next speaker
is from the University of Bremen and
he's going to talk about classification
environment by space thank you I'm very
glad to have the possibility to present
or framework here the framework I will
present as a development by the German
Research Institute of artificial
intelligence and bream and the robotics
group at the University of priam yeah
and high space stands for senior
processing and classification
environment written in Python so let's
start I will first give a brief
introduction or not too brief a more
lengthy introduction then tell you how
the software works because that's a
central part of the software then tell
you about some concepts and features of
the software and if there is enough time
i will show you some further
applications and then give a conclusion
so high space is responsible for the
computation of multiple workflows and
datasets with applications for example
in robotics and brain computer
interfaces and it has a simple
configuration and that cares for the
automatic processing of empirical
evaluations also called benchmarking it
can be applied on feature vector and
time-series data the configuration
requires no programming so if you want
to integrate or improve you should need
a programming skills but for the normal
usage you need no programming skills
there's some meat a language used which
simplifies everything I will tell you
something more about that later on and
the execution of the processing is done
in a distributed manner and has an
intuitive structure and documentation
and you can choose from more than 100
senior processing and classification
algorithms
and there are additionally interfaces to
other libraries I just medium-sized
frameworks or more than 40,000 lines of
code it's currently developed and tested
on Mac OS X and on Linux we are looking
forward to have it one day running on
Windows but we'd yet did not tested it
or had someone who was willing to
implement that or just do the
adaptations the development of the
software started six years ago but it
became only open source recently in
august 2013 there's a core developer
team of three to five people and they're
approximately 10 developers in total but
if developer means mainly people who are
integrating the algorithms to later on
test them so it's open source software
under GPR it's available on github and
documentation is also available on
github so I will tell you a bit about
the applications and somehow is
motivation why we had to develop such a
framework we had a project called the
iBot and the project was about little
immersion and control of a robot so we
have a person who's controlling robot
and just having an exoskeleton the
exoskeleton is used to directly maps and
movements into Utley of the user to the
robot the robot isn't a small picture
here and there's a virtual immersion
where you can display additional
informations to the user for example
some warnings and where we jumped in was
that we also recorded a brain signals so
EG you can see the cap there which is
the guy wearing and um it was not to
control the robot because the person can
much better control a robot but was
there to analyze the person and detect
um how we will behave and if he's got
certain information in the interface
and to improve the interface with the
signal that was the overall goal of the
project where we also used the software
was for the evaluation and comparison of
sensors selection algorithms and for
comparison and development of
dimensionality reduction algorithms and
also for the comparison and development
of class classifiers we also has already
set user for brain computer interfaces
so we could predict upcoming movements
we could detect interaction errors that
means if the interface is not behaving
as expected there's a certain brain
signal as it said it was that and that
could be detected and we could also
detect if a person perceived a warning
so if we show a warning not read
everything but just some smooth warning
but we want to know if he got us a
message or we could detect that and
first of all there were some robotic
occasions where the software is used so
for cell detection paralyzation of robot
simulations to tune some localization
algorithms and first sensor regression
yeah some more details at the end of
there's enough time so how does the
software work it will first tell you a
bit about the installation procedure
then how does the data needs to be
prepared than the most important part
how we define your processing file and
yeah then how you get it running so the
required dependencies applies in 2.7 or
thousand 2.6 you need the llamo package
you need numpy and sci-fi and there are
some optional dependencies because it
depends on what you Eggar isms you want
to use in your processing so you might
need matplotlib for visualizations
scikit-learn if you want to have an
extended access to further classifiers
and transformations you might need pike
if you want to use some gooeys the car
my a machine learning framework lip SVM
lip linea module to fight for data
processing or c4 CVX opt for some
special classifiers and some more so
when you want to install you just have
to download it install the required
dependencies and run a little script
which casts for the configuration on
your PC such that you just have to start
and software this nothing more to be
done for the data it's normally just on
the file disk and what we can access
this feature vector data from comma
separated value file or a rff adds a rff
files are the typical fights for the
vika framework you can have time to use
segments and comma separated value fats
and also processed I'm serious dreams
specified and comma separated value file
or in the EDF to format or some EG
specific formats for the data
preparation you have to tell the
framework how to access to the data so
specifies a storage format here we have
a comma separated value value fire
without any heading you have to tell
which type of data it is expecting so if
it's feature vector x use data you might
also tell the software which of the
existing factors the relevant one and
most importantly for classification you
need to tell the framework where does it
find the labels of the data in that file
let all for the data now the most
important part um how do we specify the
processing and first of all so i will
step-by-step go to studio at file
because that's our main work when we are
testing algorithm just specifying these
files and if my colleague is asking me
how did you do that processing i just
sent him the file and he knows
everything
yes it's how it works so we first define
the type of processing there are
different types of how you can process
so just some operations on data sets and
no chain means that you are have a
concatenation of egg rhythms which you
apply on your data and sample by sample
most we so then you tell them where's
the red can find the data you have
something like repetitions so if you
have some randomization in your
processing as you have it in the lip SVM
or if you are splitting your data
randomly it's good to always have
reputations to account for the
randomness and that's done with that
simple number it's just telling just
repeat everything three times and I was
the most important part there's no chain
so begins was a note was just just
accessing the data and forwarding it
then we split the data so that's just an
example just much more you can choose
but just for that example you can split
your data um forty percent training the
rest is used for testing it's randomly
split and then you can train a
normalization note so it means that your
data is normalized so you can for
example normalize the data to have zero
mean and variance of one that would be
use a Gaussian feature normalization or
you can normalize the data vectors or
feature vectors to have norm one that
would be a Euclidean future novelization
enters as much more and this check here
is just a placeholder for the egg resume
later on then you can have a support
vector machine here we use this time at
lip SVM support vector machine it's just
an interface to the classifier and you
can specify the most important parameter
or set classifier the complexity and
finally there's um just a note which
calculates all the performance matrix
which you might be interested on that
data
so far the parameters we have the
possibility to juice different numbers
for the complexity here so sweet
different numbers and two algorithms and
what the framework does it's using all
combinations of the different term
parameters which is that you specify and
runs this no train with each
specification three times there's also
possibility to specify a lot more
parameters and have some more complex
change but that's so far I think enough
so finally you might want to modify your
configuration of the software although
that's normally done by default and
everything is fine so we have a folder
where you say where's data can be found
you have a directory where you can tell
them the software wet fences
specifications for the processing you
have some logging settings and you can
furthermore modify your pricing parts if
you want to include special libraries
for example here we used a modified
implementation of the best vm and then
you start the software and starting the
software is just that line so it's this
Good Witch cares for the most part you
tell the software where to find the
configuration file and the last part
tells the software which parallelization
mode you want to use because if you want
to compare every sins and have
repetitions you run very fast into
problems with your processing because
just doing it in the serial mode will
last years so we also have that mode
it's called single Syria where you can
have one execution of a process after
the user but we can also use a
multiprocessing package on PC and we
also have a
possibility to use it software on a
class time with a scheduler called load
leveler and we implemented back end for
using it on that cluster because we're
several users and it would just would
just ran into province if we would not
use a scheduler and there's also the
possibility to use no scheduling with an
MPI back end and there's also two
possibility to add further back ends for
parallelization for example cloud or
implemented gearman bag and that's the
parallelization which you can set
butters also some paralyzation the
framework under the hood so the creation
of jobs stand imperiled during the
actual execution of the jobs and you can
also paralyzed pacific subtasks for
example if you have internally parameter
optimization it needs some additional
evaluations that can be done also in
parallel and also when you go into the
application you might want to run
different processing chains even on the
same data and also can be also done in
pella so the general structure is
oriented on the mania oriented on the
data so we have a summary which is just
a folder which contains several data
sets and the data set in our definition
is just a summary of different samples
so feature vectors and normally we are
processing a lot of data sets in
parallel so the operation on the data an
operation is something which works on
the data set and it can be concatenated
so you can modify your data merge
certain data sets apply or vica
operation on it or as already said you
can apply an old chain on that and see
no changes for us the most important
part especially for the application it's
just the concatenation of notes and
notes is just some just an elemental
algorithm which is
working on the single samples and for
the notes there are numerous algorithms
available to process the data so fearful
does sup lip sampling support vector
machines feature normalization future
generation nearly everything we need so
how does it work we have different data
sets or specification file and then the
software cares for the parallelization
and computes the different processing
chains which we specified and finally
you get some column charge some line
chart or just the process data or most
important part is some performance table
for us to look at the performance by use
and the model energy concept of the
nodes is something which we did not
invent it by our own but it was stolen
from the medulla toolkit for data
processing it's important to mention and
for the algorithms which we implement it
just so we cared for the complete
processing chain which we needed so we
when we have our time series signal we
normally begin with some pre-processing
so we have data which is was five kilo
hertz so we need some down sampling and
some additional time filtering there's
also some spatial filtering that's
something special for eg you just have
to think of it as a dimensionality
reduction algorithm applied on the
dimension of sensors and there's there's
some feature generator generators
numerous classification algorithms and
as you can also already see there are
APIs to existing libraries like the
second run algorithms or so lip linea
framework or the lip SVM classifiers I
have some post processing for future
normalization or mapping scores
visualization of data and maybe the
meter notes are also something very
important because you can include in a
meter note a sub chain or you can
optimize your parameters in there
internally in a
out here and source and sink notes for
loading and storing the data yeah and
when we implement and invent you egg
will be just integrated there and have
immediately the possibility to compare
it with existing algorithms and also
losing egg resumes developed by
colleagues so for the packets structure
we have an environment package where we
have the backends for the
parallelization some implementations for
the note and operation change so how to
concatenate these types of algorithms
some application interface and the
configuration interface for them we have
some something called missions where we
implement notes which are these parts
which are already show and some
operations which are working on the
complete data sets and something more
yeah we have our data descriptions some
scripts we also have a GUI but we mainly
work with that configuration and the
command line part especially when we're
working on the class deserts how it
works best and I have numerous tests and
some additional tools for the
documentation has already set it's on
github it's internally in our Institute
generated on daily basis to immediately
find out if there's something wrong at
least in the documentation it's based on
strings and here i want to ask who does
not know things oh that's good very good
okay and we did some modification on
things to improve our Appy documentation
a tablet customized as we want because
yeah it was not as we wanted to but it's
really really cool because it's there's
possibility to use do many many syncs
automatically and kind of tune your
documentation and subs what we did a lot
so where we have a mapping between class
names and the note egg user names so
that you can have some short names
instead of maybe long class names and
that's already displayed automatically
in the documentation
it's also displayed which input is
possible for the different notes some
examples which are included in the
documentation are automatically
generated and we have a list of all
available algorithms and that's
completely generated automatically yeah
for the testing we normally do not touch
the core functionalities such often but
if you touch it we are doing multiple
checks there are a unit test which we
run on a daily basis and I always get
some emails where check if everything is
still going right I have regular user
fees feedback and recently we
implemented generic unit tests for all
our notes because testing the notes is
the most important part so first testing
is there some documentation of the note
if there's an exemplary call existing
such that you knows at least a little
bit how to use that note if that
exemplary call is really working and
then the note is generated and applied
to some testing data and as tested if it
really works and there's also the
possibility to modify that test such
that it's more easy to implement your
own real unit test because that's just
the in generic test and for unit testing
you might need some more testing yeah
and there are scripts for running those
types of tests so I'm coming to further
applications so what you can see here is
some robot control scenario and first we
do all our optimization of the
processing or what spice place and then
we have to think about how to transfer
to the application and that's also in
inside of the framework so we have a
script code a launch life which is cares
for all the part which I needed for the
processing and so we can immediately
applies that processing in our
application for example year so Robert
control scenario and as you can see here
there's some warning displayed and we
can detect if that person not just saw
that warning because seeing could be
done with some eye tracker but we can
detect if you really got the message and
realize that it's important for the how
does it work so we have our normal
benchmarking application where we store
finally the data and follow the life
application we just process the single
samples and finally stream it to the
application where it is needed it's also
configured by mo and yeah see if we
normally we normally process different
parts of the senior and so we need
multiple processing flows which are
executed in parallel maybe come back to
that what you can see is when you have
that EEG cap on it's quite problematic
you do not want to also have be
connected to a PC PC you want to have
the possibility to go there
independently especially if you think of
the graphics at the beginning was a
exoskeleton it's you want to move freely
in your environment and so you need to
transfer the processing on a mobile
device and the mobile device you need
the mobile device which hopefully does
not require so much energy and that
approach is called repay re space so
reconfigurable the PI space and what we
do in our application is that we leave
the acquisition of the data in PI space
but then the pre processing is done and
then have a accelerated processing on an
FPGA and that's quite important because
something like DC removal and D
summation and subsampling and other part
really requires a lot of processing
power and even if you implement it and
see a it's still a lot and so on an FPGA
it's done extremely fast then we cut our
relevant parts of the signal and then we
do the post-processing so some
dimensionality reduction feature
extraction feature normalization case
classification and modification of the
special and finally sends a result wire
pass base to the interface which needs
the singer and does further on using a
gel for the processing we developed a
device quite small device 10 centimeters
times seven centimeters where we do all
the processing for the application and
where we also target on doing the
training of the application or yeah um
how much time do I have okay we have
enough time so um something where our
framework was also very very useful was
we had a evaluation on sense of
selection algorithm so if you have EG
you're using 64 channels or or sensors
and sometimes even 128 sensors and
there's always the question is there's a
possibility to reduce the number of
sensors especially for the application
it's important to really set absolute
cap fast because needing half an hour
for setting up a Kappas not that
comfortable so what sort yeah nice so we
integrated a lot of algorithms also some
algorithms which again just interfaced
already existing parts and software and
had the possibility to compare numerous
algorithms and also our for the gray
spots it's means the comparison to
random selection of sensors so
that was our baseline to have some
random selection so we had 100 random
selections for these caps and process it
and several data sets for processing so
it was really really a lot and a lot of
parameters and some internal
optimizations and so on and doing that
just in a serial way would have not been
possible and would have needed years and
yeah and finally we could see that
there's some special algorithm which was
quite good for reducing the number of
channels and we could use 40 sandals
without losing any performance what we
also it's something which we are
currently working on it's not yet public
we are also working on process on
visualizing the processing of our data
so if you're concatenating your
algorithms you sometimes want to know
what is really done with the data and
you might get to classifier wait and see
well it used that feature and that
feature but then you don't know well how
that's how did I get to feature and what
is a relation to my original data and
since we have enough framework all the
access to the separate algorithms we can
also somehow into gate of the question
on how does a concatenation of egg
rhythms works and here i have a
visualization on an extremely simple
problem which is already solved and all
but it's the best problem i guess for
understanding it's some classification
on the eminence data set just
distinction of number 0 and 1 and the
processing chain was also not that
complicated i just did a pca was using
only 40 remaining components then i had
some feature normalization and then
finding your support vector machine for
classification I know it's not
complicated but it's just for the
purpose of showing how it works or what
you can see
I asked so the question was when I have
my original data which as in weights
assigned to the single component in the
data which finally result on the
classification result and what you can
see here the red color is a part for for
the positive class the number one which
where the average shape is displayed
here with white line and the blue car is
there is important waits for the
negative class which is zero losses
obvious shape here and the green color
is for all that part which are not
relevant for the classification so I
guess that's quite helpful although one
has to admit that it's just showing the
classification weights and
classification weights do not always
tell something about the data or
sometimes difficult to interpret so to
conclude pi space is a framework which
autumn eyeses a single processing and
classification workflow let's do doing
that automatically enter parallel and
it's also possible to have other
evaluations like robot simulations or
evaluations using the Vega framework it
has an intuitive configuration without
any scripting so it's usable by
non-programmers and there's a
possibility to integrate other
algorithms and libraries so future steps
for us will be to integrate more
algorithms and also interface other
libraries to extend the number of
possible data types for example pictures
videos or multimodal data for example
combined eg data with muscle data and I
data and so on also think about further
applications so have some more support
for clustering or regression and we're
also hoping for some day have an
installation sweet although the
installation is not complex you just
have mainly to care for dependencies and
then download the software
that's a main part so thank you for your
attention thanks Mary the very nice
overview of a very practical application
using Python so now we have reopened for
questions and so I'm curious you said
you use Weka how do you interface to
Weka from Python it's quite simple
interfaces mainly using a command line
command so the operation is telling vika
where to find the files and it's
preparing the fat i'm just telling vicar
I want to have set operation with that
parameterization just run it thank you
for a presentation by space looks like
really interesting library I've seen
other libraries in Python do
configuration of machine learning models
yeah Yello files there's pie learn to
for instance that does that I was
wondering how in your experience this
scales up to very complex pipelines
because in my experience if you're
programming models any mo because that's
what you're doing is just not doing it
in Python you're doing it in llamo it
gets quite hairy after a while and after
a couple of months you get back to your
model in llamo it's like what it's a big
big big text file with many many many
many things so in your experience maybe
you know for pie space how does the
scale up to complex pipelines so the
algorithms are really implemented in PI
space but to sing algorithms I think it
means a combination might get quite
complex or if it
yeah but it's it's not just it's not
really programming inyama it's just
telling zipper it's just giving the
parameters to the processing but what is
important um we also realized that you
might want to have some more complex
parts for example test some values from
0 to 100 or as i showed in the
configuration of the sense of selection
has the numbers from 64 to one tested
and you do not want to just enter every
single number you can do that by copy
and paste and so on and there's several
other parts where you would like to have
some computation in your configuration
file and that's not easy but we
integrated that so we do not really use
a the best is the yammer as it was
originally developed but we added some
functionality to have some pison code in
there if you want to specify very
complex parts so for example if you ever
that want to have some evaluation so
having for example some logarithmic
scaling for your complexity you just say
10 to the power of your complexity and
the only modification is you put an evil
before and the software checks is that
keyword is there and then evaluates the
expression it's not easy to integrate
that in yama but after six years i think
we did it finally hi in your
classification and regression when you
use them how do you avoid the
circularity in the pre-processing like
normalization and supervised feature
selection methods circularity do you
mean visit when you use
you cannot you know you cannot use
information from the test data to okay
so so mixing testing and training data
yes how can you how do you deal with
that in the in your processing nodes so
if the user really wants to mix training
and testing data and just doing it on
purpose we cannot avoid it but by
default the framework is totally and
completely separating training and
testing data and even let the
pre-processing for the pre-processing
everything is assumed to be a testing
data most of the time and you really
have to specify what is the training
data and normally we have complete
separate processing of the training date
training and testing data so its treated
as completely separate you can also
specify that in your normal data so if
you have the endless data that's already
specified which is training and testing
data but we first use only the training
data to give it to the algorithms and
train it and later on we give the
testing data but we skip the labels so
in the normal data execution the labels
and the data are completely separated so
you have normally no access to it you
can cheat always sheet but the cuspid
are not really on purpose end and so how
do you write difficult so how do you do
normalization for example with how do
you normalize the data before you do
need to the classifiers so there are
several algorithms for doing the feature
normalization yeah if you have something
like just normalizing the vectors to the
norm of one you do not need any training
but if you want to have something like
map the data to a certain interval you
have to specify beforehand what is your
training data and what is your testing
data otherwise the software crashes and
taught you well I did not get any so you
cannot do cross validation in what we
can we can but that's something you have
to specify beforehand so you have to
tell so
when we have that dressing shame here
there we have the train test splitter
you can also just integrate the CV
splitter there's a note how many splits
to use and then it's splitting the data
and doing everything automatically and
also in the evaluation you have
different performance values for the
different splits and it's completely
treated separately and what may be
important for the cross-validation
between the processing of the splits the
no chain is completely reset so yeah
you're welcome any any further questions
thanks for the presentation can you
handle that it streams also or just
offline data sets for the application we
need to process data streams so it's
always the question if it's possible to
interface it we have some different
types implemented for accessing data
streams it's possible it's yeah but
normally you might later on one to
separate this data stream according to
certain signals in this part but for
example for if we want to predict in
movement we are really processing the
complete stream so every 50 milliseconds
icing we are processing the data having
at the beginning just taking some
complete streams and later on
calculating some windows but still in a
stream manner and then processing it and
just giving a reply every 50
milliseconds thank you you're welcome I
have a question regarding the signal
processing so you so you use a
particular hardware to detect signals
from the neurons
from the brains here and how how does it
work in the field I mean these are
usually very sensitive to interference
from other devices so when you do you
use some sort of cleaning method to to
cancel out the noise and things like
that is that a problem we also test
methods on that so we have had a guy who
was implementing artifact removal parts
for example to delete the I artifact
parts just to be sure that we are
focusing on the brain singer are not on
the icing and that's done and we also do
sometimes evaluations where we check if
we remove certain artifacts by hand and
then do the classification is it still
working or is it were so that we know
are we relying on artifact and also that
visualization part which we started or
nearly finished as part of that just to
find out are we really looking at the
right signal and yeah is it just looking
on artifacts but another important part
is what we realized is that due to our
filtering normally the artifacts are
just removed automatically and we do not
have to care your sake tags any any
further questions from the audience ok
if that's not the case let's thank our
speakers
you
you